but told to take Sam E. for Liberty Talks vacation, but it has folate in it,
there's mental tetrahedral folate, and vitamin B12 as mental cobalty. I remember reading
in your book, not taking anything that is methylated. What is your opinion?
Well, I'm not a big fan of taking Sam E. anyhow, because Sam E is not necessarily a
horrible, but it doesn't work on a negative feedback loop to block the materiality pathway.
So personally, I don't know that I am ever carried Sam E. and you, Sam E. for my patients.
Now, Sam E is used to be, I don't know how, because I've kind of been out of that realm for a
number of years. Sam E used to use a lot with people with mood disorders. Now, the issue with it is
sometimes it makes people worse. The reason why it would make people worse is because I've just
that. Most Sam E products also contain a lot of methyl groups. And if you take too many methyl groups
and you didn't take a deep enough dive on your genetics, and you have defects in your biopter and pathway,
especially the pathway that makes serotonin, you can actually, you don't clear serotonin very well.
And too many methyl groups will push that pathway and you'll have excess serotonin. Now, most people
think that serotonin is your happy neurotransmitter. And it makes you happy that people with two little
serotonin have depression, head serotonin, uptake inhibitors, which block the uptake of serotonin,
leading block the clearance of serotonin from receptor sites. But the truth is it's the imbalance that's
the issue. So if you have excess serotonin, then you can end up having, you know, anger issues,
rage issues, all sorts of other mood disorders. So even if a person does not have cancer. So let's
say, first of all, it's not have cancer, contact us suddenly. They want help with their genetics,
and so we're trying to assist them with their genetics. You want to look at all the different pathways
to make sure that you're not using a supplement and pushing a pathway that you don't want to push
because of defects. That is probably the most common issue with non-cancer patients
to taking excess methyl groups. And I would say the most common errors that naturopaths or
carpractors made, that understanding the full genetic picture. So now for a cancer patient,
it's a whole different follow-ups. Access methyl groups in a cancer patient will actually
silence tumor suppressor genes. So you have genes inside each cell that if the cell goes into
rapid replication, your tumor suppressor system kicks on. Now you've heard of some of these genes
before, P53 gene. That's the most research tumor suppressor gene, but probably the most spoken
about is the bronca genes. So bronca genes are tumor suppressor genes. Now there's a whole bunch of
tumor suppressor genes, caros genes, p10 genes, and a whole bunch of different tumor suppressor systems.
God put all those inside yourself. Now what silences those is methyl groups. If you have excess methyl
groups inside the cell, you'll basically turn those genes off. So you will block, you'll
in effect block what's called the intrinsic meaning inside the cell, the intrinsic apoptotic pathway.
That's the pathway inside the cell that causes a stimulation of cell destruction. So if the cell is
gone bad, you know, whether it's in rapid replication, like a cancer cell, or it's become toxic,
that cell needs to die, or it's become infected, that cell needs to die. Now your tumor suppressor
gene will kick on and cause an intrinsic apoptotic capsaic pathway. Stimulates this capsaic pathway.
Think I have some videos on it somewhere that stimulates cell destruction. So the cell will kill
itself and you won't get cancer, or you will help fight cancer. So certainly when a person has cancer,
you don't want excess methyl groups. Certainly you don't want excess methyl groups ever. And it has been
an error, I think, in the naturopathic slash nutritional slash chiropractic community to give people
too many methyl groups. And for this very reason, that it could actually lead to a cancer growth that
would normally be destroyed through the intrinsic apoptotic pathway.
Besides the fact that it could lead to excess biopterant issues,
ex-pushing the biopterant pathway and causing mood disorders. And there's so much things. I mean,
I just, so long, long way too long answer to your question, you were told to take
Sammy for liver detoxification. I wouldn't do that. Sammy is in methyl, a methylation is a small piece
of the liver detoxification pathway. Get your methyl groups naturally through eating
folate, rich nutrients in your food. That's why I tell people, okay, you're not ever going to be
deficient to folate. You're not going to be deficient in methyl groups. You're not going to have a
in, you're not going to have a hypo methylation. Even if you have C677MTHFR or C1298MTHFR defects,
you're not going to have hypo methylation if you're eating greens. So most of our cancer patients are
eating salads, they're eating greens. The people that end up with a hypo methylation issue are people
that have double allele defects at C777, especially that, or double allele defect at C1298.
And they are like, they don't eat any vegetables, okay, so they're the people that
they'll maybe kids, maybe need some extra methyl groups. So it's, I personally would take that.
There's other ways to help with liver detoxification that I would not use that product.